et spent nearly four decades with
Florence Henderson and tonight our most
unforgettable moments remembering Mrs
Brady and we are the only show with
three of her Brady kids starting with
Marsha Lee McCormack so here's the story
of a TV icon who was part of all of our
families what was your immediate
reaction when you heard the news just
total disbelief just total disbelief I
had just been with her I just seen her I
think everyone was shocked marine fought
back tears this morning remembering the
woman who played her TV mom and became
one of her best friends Florence was
even texting her love as she competed on
Dancing with the Stars she said hi sweet
marine I got so many calls and messages
saying how wonderful you were the state
and you were thanks so much for dinner
and her actual very last television
performance was for you on Dancing with
the Stars where she came out said Marsha
Marsha Marsha Marsha Marsha Marsha what
was that moment like it was amazing it
was amazing it was so great to be with
her I'm so proud of you been watching
him that way and then just one week ago
she was in the audience for the show's
finale three days later on Thanksgiving
she passed away at La cedars-sinai
Medical Center the cause of death was
heart failure no word yet on funeral
plans we show marine our last interview
at Florence it was just two months ago
you got very emotional when you saw
marine dance what what were you feeling
then well you know I know what Maureen's
life has been like and all she's been
through and you know I still feel like
she's mine and so I love her very much
I'm her she's mine I mean how lucky how
lucky I am how lucky we all are
Florence's heart
was so good you know it's so funny
because you know yeah she played this
mother that you know many people joke
about or say oh you know it's just so
sweet and everything but you know what
she was that sweet
she really was it was the lovely lady
they sing about in the Brady songs she
was the loveliest the loveliest of
ladies so if you could say anything to
Florence right now what would it be
thank you
thank you
forever